Hello, this is Dr. Kevin Cutters and we're starting the series on a poptosis, so if you don't know what that word means
You're gonna learn all sorts of things about it. This is
Gonna start slow but get kind of advanced through this series
So it's kind of like a we're gonna call it a college level course a poptosis. What a what is where we're gonna start?
A little bit more simplistic, but when we get to 6.0.1
Stay with me if you will please because that's what we really get into some things that you can do from a natural perspective to stimulate this thing called a poptosis
That's what you want to do if you're dealing with a diagnosis of cancer. So stay with me
There'll be a lot to go through with this
So a poptosis one of what the definition of a poptosis is
normal
Cell death
Normal programmed cell death. This is a normal process that we want ourselves to go through. There's only
There's only a very specific amount or type of cells that don't go through a poptosis in our body
Both cells go through a poptosis. That means they have a life cycle
They have a life span and they live that life span and that our body gets rid of them through a normal
physiological process. It's been called cell
Suicide because that's what really takes place inside the cell. There's two different processes and intrinsic and extrinsic process that will
that will
Explained and nauseam in our more advanced little levels here
But it is really a normal process that our cells go through to
To create a new cell you to your body is a new body
Over time. Yes, it might be degenerated because as we age we reproduce a less than
Healthy cell that it was previous and so that's part of the aging process, but if we did it go through a poptosis
We did that all with cancer. So we'll discuss this as we go
here
So there's two real ways that cells die in our body
What is a poptosis that we're going to go over the other is the creusis so the creusis is different than a poptosis and we're going to
Explain that a poptosis is what I said a purposeful
Stimulation it's induced by the cell or the cell membrane and
It's purposeful to get rid of that cell because that cell already produced a baby cell and now this mother cell
It's time for it to die
It requires energy. It's gobbled up by
Macrophages which are part of your white blood cell your TH1 system. It a process called phagocytosis
So there's no waste
It's all very
Conserved. It's very detailed. It's a it's a detailed process
So as I said, it's normal. It can be pathological
Meaty we'll discuss that like chemotherapy and radiation produces a pathological a poptosis
But if we didn't have that if there was no radiation poisoning or something like that then
We'd just be talking about the normal physiological a poptosis
On the other hand the creusis is toxicity induced
It's passive the cell is it purposefully killed itself it releases waste the cell is being murdered
So one way to look at it a poptosis is is normal death of the cell the creusis is
Someone from the outside murdering the cell the cell didn't want to die had no purpose and died
But it was killed by an outside factor
It is always pathological the creusis is
So it's important to understand the difference in this it has a different effect on our body too
When our cells go through a poptosis they start to shrink will explain that and they're basically imploding upon themselves
They break off into little TD bodies and
Those little TD bodies are gobbled up by these hungry macrophages that gobbled up and eat it up the components of that
That cell that are
Conserved it's recycled so apoptosis is a natural
Recycling of our cell genetic material. So nothing goes to waste in apoptosis
It's not inflammatory so normal program cell death doesn't cause a huge amount of inflammation
Doesn't cause any
Degeneration there's no bad things happening in apoptosis. It's a normal event and it happens one by one
Versus necrosis it can involve many so necrosis because of let's say a bacterial infection that's eroding away your skin
Many cells are dying. It's giving off tons of waste tons of inflammation. You're losing cell components
There's absolutely no recycling going on. It's just waste waste waste. The cells are exploding. They're rupturing
Cell components are going all over. There's no recycling taking place. That is a that is a
Terroristic attack on a cell structure necrosis is
Versus apoptosis is someone living to 95 years old and died and
The wonderful funeral explains the wonderful life of this individual and everybody's happy that they moved on
Now to heaven. That's apoptosis
So the program of apoptosis that we'll get into here in our later little lectures
It causes the cell to start shrinking. So you see my little arrow there on the apoptosis side
If you look at this picture, this has a normal cell and the left is necrosis taking place
And you look at the end of the crosis's cell material being spewed out no
Recycling taking place the cell was murdered on the right hand side. You see apoptosis. It starts to shrink
Things are being destroyed from the inside out and will explain that in detail and eventually these little
Shapes take place on the outside of the cell membrane. It starts to break off
These are called blabs. They're indented membrane surfaces start to indent to put itself and then
Specific lipid molecules stick to that cell surface and they're attracted. They're like little
Sancy things so
Macrophages white blood cells go. Oh, there's something looks really good over there
I can smell it. That is a dying cell and
Macrophages, which are white blood cells
Sniff out these dying cells and they go all these look really tasty and they gobble up these little blabs
And they recycle that material and everything goes exactly the way it was supposed to
So our next piece we're going to get it to why this is important because it is so so important. I love to garden
And if you don't
Prood your carrot patch
You are never going to get a good crop of carrots. If you don't prove your tomatoes if you don't prove your apple tree
You're never going to get a good crop of apples. You have to do this. This is part of life
It's it's just what takes place in a healthy environment is this shaping or pruning
We see pruning take place in an embryological
neurological
System and we're going to get into this pruning and why this is important in our next
Session with this I'm trying to keep these short so they're just not too much information
But let's sum this up apoptosis could is very controlled your body is controlling this your body is
Desiring apoptosis
So it's a programmed pathway. It's very specific and very detailed
And this is why we're going to see why different things like viruses and bacteria and
Toxins and poisons could affect this
Intracellularly be the inside the cell I can break the pathway so that apoptosis doesn't take place and of course
We know if you listen to any of my other lectures
That's what cancer is so what is cancer a cell that doesn't go through apoptosis what it was supposed to
And a cell that instead of it reproducing every six weeks or 12 weeks or 18 weeks
Now it's producing six or 12 or 18 times a day. It's reproducing itself
So there's a broken pathway. There's a broken apoptotic pathway. It's not dying in a broken replication pathway
So we're going to get into the details of what chemical
Pathways these are
As simplistic as I could make them for everybody, but it is important to know that that's what cancer is
Sell that going through apoptosis and a cell stuck in a rapid replication cycle. That's the definition of cancer
So these pathways can be broken
Apoptosis is purposeful. It has a purpose. It cleans up the body
It's pruning cells that don't need to be there anymore that have lived their lifespan
It is normal. It is typically not pathological the way we're going to discuss it in apoptosis
So what we're going to talk about the pathological type of apoptosis with chemotherapy and radiation
And it's very different from the crosis
apoptosis is normal life span of a cell died off and having a wonderful funeral
The crosis is being attacked by a terrorist group, but it's killing multiple cells
sprued sprued a huge ugly mess all over
apoptosis is
So-so-so necessary to prevent cancer. That's why we're going to talk about this
So how can we stimulate a normal healthy apoptosis?
It sells that art going through that
so stay tuned for next episode or next class on apoptosis 2 or 1
So watch for that. I hope this helps and I hope you read blessed